[Music]
today an arts 21 special
[Music]
women say times up muse maestra me too
and the global consequences
how has women's protests changed the
arts are we on the verge of a new type
Geist everybody is talking about it
so are we our arts 21 special with Karen
Halstead at Deutsche Welle global media
forum in Bonn
the big debate with four international
women who speak up to this special
edition of Arts 21 at the global media
forum today here in Bonn my name is
Karen homestead and it's a great
pleasure to be here eight months into
the post me to era we've seen it spawned
countless other protests most notably
The Times up campaign and the
interesting thing and striking thing
about these protests is that they
started in the cultural sector which
raises of course the questions how
powerful is culture how powerful are
women in culture in the wake of me to
Time magazine made the silence breakers
its collective Person of the Year for
2017 saying their actions unleashed one
of the highest velocity shifts in our
culture since the 1960s well we'd like
to see just how much that statement can
hold up can this movement empower women
globally or are we with our Western
perspective perhaps overestimating its
reach
and here are my guests from all over the
world the renowned Indian feminist
author and publisher Vashi
boo Thalia she spent her entire career
bringing women's stories and subjects
like sexual violence into the public
discussion and she says the women's
movement in India is one of the
strongest in the world please give her a
warm round of applause an award-winning
poet publisher and journalist from
Lebanon is with us today breaking taboos
and sparking discussions of women's
sexuality in the Arab world are her main
beats since many years most recently she
ran for a seat in the Lebanese
Parliament welcome Jumana Haddad okay
yellow is a French journalist author
filmmaker and activist such a long list
I can hardly read it all and has
published racism a guide and she's very
outspoken on issues of freedom of
expression and how in her experience
harassment can be closely related to
racism a warm round of applause please
and last but not least Ellen Harrington
is an American curator and film
programmer in January she took over as
director of the German Film Institute in
Frankfurt for over two decades she
worked for the Academy of Motion
Pictures Arts and Sciences in Los
Angeles and as such experience the me to
debate at very close range a warm
welcome to all of you round of applause
thank you for joining us rather than
fade out me to continues to have an
almost daily ripple effect in the news
and so before we get started we're going
to have a quick recap of the turbulent
times of meeting women in Chile are
protesting it's become a huge
demonstration like never before in this
country against sexism and violence
he may be the one who got the ball
rolling inadvertently Harvey Weinstein
once a powerful movie mogul now indicted
on charges of rape he ruled over a
cartel of silence that is over no more
shame no more silence he led me to his
bathroom pleading that I just watched
him masturbate time was up a worldwide
outcry followed a flood of revelations
among them the Swedish Academy in
Stockholm it announced that the Nobel
Prize in Literature will be cancelled
this year the venerable institution now
has shambles after a sexual assault
scandal across all industries cultural
political or big business women are
speaking out and men are forced to face
up even if some wish it would all
disappear sooner than later Yeah right
dare we look into the future what will
remain of me - and time's up in 5 10 15
years one thing certain Hollywood will
turn it all into a movie director Brian
De Palma is currently working on a
script based on the Harvey Weinstein
scandal a real horror film
we are definitely not gonna put that one
at the top of our to see list I'm pretty
sure but just back from LA
Ellen Harrington you spent 25 years at
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences so in the middle of Weinstein's
world so to speak how did you experience
the Weinstein affair and the ensuing me
to debate well what I think is so
fascinating is that what the journalists
who discovered this story and got the
women to go on record with the New York
Times and the The New Yorker magazine
did was they broke through a cartel of
silence and an actual system of
intimidation that was incredibly
pervasive and ironically Harvey
Weinstein's attorney last week stated
that his defense was that he didn't
invent the casting couch and it's true
the entire history of the industry of
the movie industry entertainment in
general women are a product and
generally men are the architects of
what's being shown and it's always
unfortunately been this way ironically
in the silent era there were more women
directors and writers than there are now
and so when you look at the statistics
and who's getting to tell the stories
what I'm really hoping is that the
normalization of that kind of
institutional sexism and abuse which
really you know from top to bottom
people really did know about this and
journalists tried to break that story
for decades and there was a conspiracy
of silence and a lot of intimidation
tactics actually to prevent it from
being told I'm hoping this flips
inscript
and that the new normal and the new
normalization is that women do get a
seat at the table and they do get to
start being the architects of stories
that are told in the culture are we
seeing any changes already what's the
atmosphere now you were just in LA it's
very different than six months ago I
will definitely say in terms of who the
agencies are submitting for director
jobs looking at the actual hard facts
that you know there's three percent of
films that are shot by women in
cinematography Department numbers are
stones ridiculous 9 percent of the top
250 films made in Hollywood last year
were directed by women and when you see
films like black
there for example that not only address
strong women roles but you know minority
and diverse performances those films
actually get a very high amount of
profit and a very high viewership
compared to their investment and the
people in charge in the industry have
been ignoring the business facts in
order to stay comfortable so have we I
think we've been seeing some change
though at some of that for instance
Cannes Film Festival the belly not in
Berlin we're seeing actually a rise in
what's being bought up by the production
companies of female-driven narratives
yes already and absolutely having Cate
Blanchett and that group of women on the
jury in can all of the you know the
staging of a protest on the steps of the
Film Festival it is actually changing
business practices
the inclusion waiver which is something
where if someone has power in the
industry a strong cast producer they can
actually require that there's a certain
amount of diversity in the
below-the-line cast and in the staffing
of the production and it makes a
difference when women are in charge they
hire more women when a diverse group of
people are in charge they hire more
diverse people and that's how you get
more representation in the industry
people need the door open they need a
job opportunity okay now you've been six
months in Germany it's not a long time
but I'm sure you have some impressions
you've been you've been dancing at a lot
of weddings so tell us how you see
things here is is the industry moving
here
well Germany already has a very
different funding model and there's a
lot more women directors here and when
women who are getting their films
distributed you know in narrative as
well as documentary and the cultural
political scene here is addressing me
too quite directly certainly at the
opening of the Berlin alley and also at
the Deutsche film prize the awards
commentators and also the presenters and
the government ministers who spoke very
specifically addressed me too and times
up and said it's a big part of their
agenda to make sure that this doesn't
fade away okay so a relatively seismic
shift in the u.s. I suppose we can say
me too of course started off as a
protest of well-to-do Hollywood stars
but very quickly achieved a global
dimension and across multiple industries
how relevant
was it in your country or Vashi Italia
because I'm thinking women in India are
also looking to some other moments in
history as as perhaps more seismic yeah
for us actually what you're now calling
the me to moment in the West wasn't what
you addressed in your introduction a
ripple effect or what's happening in the
United States because much though you
know I respect what the United States is
doing in many respects but it's not the
center of the world from where things
were pull out and there are things going
on in other parts of the world which are
born of the local histories so for us
actually it was in the early 90s that
the process of giving a name to this
really widespread problem began and it
began because of the history of a poor
village woman who while performing her
task as a government functionary
was raped in the village where she was
working by four men and they raped her
because they didn't like her trying to
stop child marriage and it led to a huge
debate inside the women's movement about
what comprises the workplace for women
is it just the four walls of an office
space or is it out in the fields inside
a domestic space and so on and so forth
and thus began the battle we filed a
petition with the Government of India to
bring in place a law on sexual
harassment in the workplace that came in
2013 after which it has become mandatory
for all businesses universities
educational institutions everybody who
has more than 10 employees to have
committees in place and to deal with the
subject and that has coincided with a
sort of expansion in which women who are
coming out into the public space and
facing discrimination and seeing how
male bias operates in the public space
they are speaking out more and more and
demanding change so it's a very live
subject it's everywhere of course it is
they of course yeah there are part of a
lot of women to address the subject yes
and the momentum is yes and the
articulation of it is of course with
literate and urbanized women who can
speak out and who have access but it's
not to say that poorer women in
are not complaining of the lack of
safety and lack of security in in
working so it's said to be a big
movement let's see what happens okay and
it's very rooted in the culture of the
home being the women's space and the
public space belonging to men okay thank
you or Vashi for that let's come over to
you Jumana we're talking about 500
million women in India quite as a much
smaller number in Lebanon how relevant
was me to in Lebanon and has it hasn't
had an impact of tangible well I
personally didn't feel a real impact
obviously there has been people talking
about it but to tell you the truth
even though I know that healing starts
with breaking the silence this is the
first most important step in any culture
and any problem but we still lack the
courage to address this issue in a very
open open way I mean I know that sexual
harassment is widespread that sexual
intimidation is widespread as well at
work because you know harassment is a
very broad word what does it mean does
it mean my boss trying to intimidate me
into doing something just because I'm
afraid to lose my job which happens a
lot and many times in in my country and
in other countries or does it only mean
you know touching someone or you know
it's about power it's a power play the
fact that you say it makes it easier for
others to say it as well but
unfortunately it always takes a famous
person to say it in order to a lot of
well there's an element of shame we're
like a waitress being harassed by a bar
owner in a small American town we
wouldn't have heard about it maybe as
much as we did because of who Harvey
Weinstein is and who the actresses are
yes exactly
okay yeah hello I'm gonna come over to
you because the the reaction in France
in this initially in France a rather
uncomfortable backlash can you tell us
about that yes so it was
kind of discrepancy between the reaction
that you could see on social media among
the younger generation of feminists and
the generation of the most famous French
actresses yes there was there was there
was a journalist named Sandra Miller who
studied the ashtag balance topo which
was a local translation Alsatian of the
media movement but there was also a
column that was written by several
actresses including Catherine Deneuve
and many of many other MEA yeah yeah it
is a bit wavy and some other leading
French women who were saying that they
who are rather supportive to men and
saying that they were defending the
freedom of bothering of annoying women
in the public spaces so that was quite
difficult because they have a white echo
and a friend so it was difficult for us
French women is to say that we you know
there was not an anonymous voice against
the meet you in France but I have to say
that before the meeting of making
friends that there have been a kind of
first wave of reaction related to
something that happened to a woman it
was in 2011 when the diminished host can
yes we was running for further French
presidency what was you know involved in
a rape in New York that was something
that really had a white echo in France
that marys understand that many that
there was much sort of solidarity
between some men that were standing with
Dominique strauss-kahn but to me it was
the start of you know a new generation
of feminists to race and to be to go
public and the mutual movement
finally make people able to say and to
prevent home and Polanski for example
hosting a very prestigious ceremony in
cinema exactly now you mentioned
obviously famous people need to speak up
in France of course we also just saw the
process the protest of very high-profile
women in film and black actresses also
took advantage of the Cannes Film
Festival to stage a protest which was
also widely reported hope
yeah do you think me too as we see it
become more and more inclusive can be
leveraged for more change in terms of
women of color women and women of color
being taken seriously in terms of in as
artists as creative agents is it helpful
I think that Demitri movement is
attached to celebrities made me yes it
means that there are some women who do
the work on the ground at the grassroot
level and who are not acknowledged by
the you know the media and we really
need you to say and to tell that it's
thank to them that we're here today and
the the media movement can really
inspire a very diverse type of women's
you kind of tackle their very specific
position as being you know women whether
they care whether the women of color or
you know disabled women women are the
kind of women's I'm just wondering if
their thoughts on why the time was right
it was so right now for this to just
take off the way the way it has yeah but
before that I would like to say one
thing because you mentioned that I was
saying that more famous people should
have the guts to speak up and I was
actually saying the opposite we should
pay more attention to regular people
speaking up I think that's why their
media is very important unfortunately
they seek without generalizing the
sensational part of any story so an
actress a famous actor saying that this
producer harassed me or raped me is way
more sellable than a regular person a
regular woman saying that while it
happens everyday to regular women and
they do try to speak up but no one is
listening so it's very important for us
to learn to listen and not just link
give importance to those who are famous
to the shiny part of any story because
it also deprives it of its strength and
of its you know
depth I mean of course they have
suffered I mean all these actresses have
suffered but in a way and I'm gonna be
the bad woman saying that they also have
waited all these years in order to speak
up while it would have been
way better to many others to just say no
beginning I'm I don't want to blame the
victim but I have to speak about a
certain responsibility thank you very
much for that comment
me too obviously was all about speaking
up and Jumana very early on and long
before me too as well you were breaking
taboos and bringing the body and issues
of women's sexuality into the
conversation in the arab world not an
easy task let's have a quick look at
this
shattering taboos in the Arab world the
art magazines Assad celebrates the
female body and female sexuality
Jumana Haddad is founder of the
provocative magazine and is demanding
self-determination for women she says
women's power lies in their femininity
and eroticism in her books Haddad puts
an end to the traditional Arab image of
women she says I'd kill Scheherazade the
malleable playmate and want emancipated
combative women an angry reckoning with
patriarchy revolutionary in the Arab
world when killing Chehalis are trying
to create a new model what reactions did
you get to your work well obviously
which was very much expected I had the
haters and you know the threateners and
I had the supporters I mean it's because
I mean these issues were not only for me
about challenging my own society and
what they have been telling me to be or
say or do since my early childhood
because this was I think depriving me of
one of my most basic and sacred rights
which is my freedom but it was also
about challenging that the stereotypes
in the West you know and not all Arab
women are submissive or oppressed or
veiled or I didn't park my camel outside
okay you know all these images and you
do you think that it's a joke but some
people still think this way about Arab
women until now I mean this is
unfortunately why you need to have a
healthy kind of curiosity and why the
media is important it's important too
for the media to not just seek the story
of the woman who has been abused by her
husband the aunt has been stoned to
death because for veiled women she was a
she she dared to love someone else but
also the successful Arab woman and there
are lots
them out there lots of them it's
interesting looking back at just add
that one of the biggest subscriber
groups that you had was from Saudi
Arabia
obviously a country where big big
changes have been happening for women
and that was of course cause for great
optimism in in recent months the driving
ban for women supposed to be lifted on
the 24th of this month and then very
surprisingly
in the past weeks a really harsh
crackdown on prominent Saudi women
activists multiple arrests and leading
to an extremely troubling and
contradicting situation we actually have
a Saudi viewer in our in our audience on
coming back to you mana but I'm gonna go
over to her and just introduce her for a
second
and a fact let's get you to stand up and
give her a round of applause if I
downloaded it from Saudi Arabia I'd like
to know what you've what are your
thoughts on these developments in Saudi
Arabia and how hopeful are you for for
real change for women in that country
because of the last moles that heaven in
Saudi Arabia
crown prince is supporting women now and
we are so happy about that because if
the rules come from up society and the
culture will change but if it's come
from down to up it will not happen in
Saudi Arabia I'm talking about my
country because the system in my country
working like this it is very difficult
to make move from down to up shouldn't
he come from up to down
on the other hand it looks like he
thought things were going just a little
too quickly with all the crackdowns and
and arrests of Saudi women activists so
what does that tell us obviously people
were then some I don't think it will
stop anything that it will continue that
liberation yes and I think what will
happen after few days as a very clear
action to to prove to all the world that
the change in Saudi Arabia is real okay
so obviously optimism on your part out
of fat thank you very much for for
contributing that
I'd like to come back to user mana what
are your thoughts on what's going on in
Saudi Arabia and how hopeful are you I
mean you're you're looking at the Arab
world a different a different view on
the Arab world a different Arab country
in life fortunately I'm not hopeful at
all no because we are missing times
where religious radicalism is on the
rise it's you know it's like a graph
it's up and down and now it's up and you
cannot mix religion with governance and
expect good things you cannot I mean
this is a luxury that I cannot afford
I've been disappointed too many times
and the Arab world and most Arab
countries are very far from this
separation nowadays and I mean I do I'm
glad that finally women in Saudi Arabia
can can be in the 20th century they're
still not in 2018 but I'm glad they're
at least able to to drive cars but can
you imagine that we are applauding a
country just because it allowed people
something so absurd and their home Allah
women as as to drive a car why should we
I mean they should have done this a long
time ago I mean at least allow women to
decide for themselves make a return what
they wanted you how that when they want
to travel how they want to live what I
say is that as a woman you should be
free to do whatever you want to do with
your body if you want to wear hijab you
should be fit to wear it if you don't
want to want to wear a hijab you should
be supported in order not to wear it and
what's going on for example now in Iran
is very interesting because women are
protesting in the street to to to
protest against the fact that the hijab
is is mandatory and you even see women
with hijab supporting the non Hydrabad
sisters in their right not to wear it
and that's something I tried to very
make really make here because there is
something that is very patronizing when
you see a woman who wears her hijab and
you say you know to me feminism means to
be uncovered any comments on on on this
veil debate we
for we start you know defending the
right of women to wear the veil let us
ask ourselves and ask them were they
forced to wear the veil or did they
choose to wear the veil my point is to
say that Muslim women are not a monolith
if you wear a hijab in France it doesn't
have the same meaning as as you wear it
in South Arabia yes I think it's very
interesting you know India has the
second largest Muslim population in the
world after Indonesia and Muslim women
in India are covered and not covered and
you know dress in any which way they
please there is hardly any place in the
country where there is pressure but
there is a very interesting way in which
Muslim women are claiming feminism so
I'm not as claiming feminism from within
religion and I'm not as negative or as
pessimistic as you are about even Saudi
women being able to drive because I
think one thing is what the state gives
you but the other is what comes up from
the ground and what women fight for and
even a small write like that can
actually be quite empowering to the
women and one can't dismiss what that
means some of the struggles of Muslim
women in India have been to reclaim
Muslim shrines which they want to be
able to visit which were only open to
men and they won that battle
but you know I want to come back briefly
to what we began with the me2 movement
and the point that both of you were
making which is about how you get to see
in the media the high profile actors in
this actually to me the movement against
sexual violence which is embodied partly
in the me2 movement is really important
worldwide because it has the potential
to link the women's movement worldwide
in a way that many issues have not done
in recent years we have been very
divided on many of our issues here's
something that links us all together but
we have to remember and the media since
we are talking in a media house where
the media have to remember that you
can't only look at the big stories
you have to look at the smaller stories
and the fact that there's so much focus
on me - in the United States and within
Hollywood but you forget everything else
that's happening across the world is to
me symbolic of the fact that it's a
white woman led movement and black women
are forgotten in it the fact that Arab
women have disappeared from it and the
fact that things that are happening in
our countries are just completely
invisible including the fact that
everywhere in the world women are
stepping out and claiming public spaces
much more than they were before and
that's really threatening in the United
States clearly the whole meets you and
time's up movement was generated by
celebrity but it's actually had a
fantastic trickle-down effect there's
been really millions of people empowered
and also just the sheer outrage actually
you know people in the United States are
really really angry right now because
the country really is being run by a
misogynist
thank you very much Ellen for that
comment obviously I'd like to get to the
situation in India where women are also
fighting not only gender battles but
also issues of class and caste and and
poverty and so on and return to your
statement the statement I opened with
about you with the Indian women's
movement here in the West are our
perception of India is obviously highly
polarized on the one hand you mentioned
Bollywood romantic exaggerated cliches
but then on the other hand they're
shocking incidents of rape what can you
tell us there to kind of give us a more
differentiated view of the reality of
women in India that you see well I think
it's actually it's unfortunate that the
image of India that gets projected is
either of a terribly spiritual country
which it is not a very materialistic in
many ways or of a country that's
terribly violent where it's towards its
women and this is not to say violence
does not exist but it is also a country
which is actually fantastically
country full of opportunities for women
where women have really reached the top
in many ways without any family backing
so the you know the entire banking
industry is headed by women we've had
extremely powerful politicians I mean
there's any number of things and it's
again one has to look at things in a
nuanced way if you look at sexual
violence statistically in the world and
if you look at UN statistics on the rate
per rape of hundred thousand people
you'll be surprised to know that India
is 1.2 on that scale the United States
is twenty seven point eight the UK is
twenty eight point something Sweden is
sixty three South Africa is 120 I'm just
citing the statistics that I remember so
what is it about India that creates this
image and I think there it's a very
complicated picture but partly I think
those of us have been involved in the
women's movement are to blame because we
have kept the issue of sexual violence
towards women on the public agenda we
will not let it go off the agenda
because we want changes and we want it
to be addressed and the media has sided
with us in very interesting ways so
every case gets into the papers I don't
want to take a nationalistic stance and
pretend that we are great we're not but
I think is much more complicated and I
think that we need to understand also
where women are placed culturally and
all the kinds of beliefs and things
which become sedimented over time and
which become ways of imposing certain
expected behaviors on women and
bollywood fed into this right up to the
gills until recently when with the entry
of new young women directors it began to
change and now you're getting these
amazing films which are made by women
directors produced by women which start
with knowing female stories they're a
female there is a recent film called vad
wedding which is about really
women's sexual lives and it's amazing
which brings me to the question of how
artistic creation can actually help to
break down stereotypes we will talk
about that just in one second but first
we're going to look at an exhibition of
Indian women artists and it's currently
happening in vogue vogue let's have a
look
bracelets fired into bricks but not just
ordinary bracelets they all come from
violated women deaf room is an
installation by Indian feminist artist
Bharti cure next to it six women bodies
made of plaster of sex workers in
Kolkata
the exhibition facing India in voice
walk is showing works by six young
Indian artists projective pot nice uses
the refrigerator as a symbolic setting
the kitchen is ascribed to women in
India with strict hierarchies and rules
people from the lower caste conscious
enter into a kitchen of a higher caste
Brahmin also women if they have
menstruation happening they are not
supposed to enter kitchens the central
theme of this show borders and their
dissolution as in meat who sends works
her motley collection of replicated
organs and teeth is a strong rejection
of the dividing lines between castes
ethnic groups and genders
as far as the cultural scene women's
position in the in the cultural scene in
India in general young women artists in
India of breaking taboos quite amazingly
on issues of sexuality on issues of
religion and doing some really
fascinating work I think a lot of young
women are breaking these cultural
stereotypes and creating new and
different cultures which will not be
silenced and I think what becomes
worrying and really dangerous you spoke
of religion is when religion combines
with political power and fundamentalism
to impose cultural taboos on women and
that's happening in India now and it's
very scary even in the United States if
you think about it the radical right
fits the radical religion radical of
days this is what I always say and you
think about it the right is not Pro
women it's not pro-choice
it's not Pro freedom it's very
oppressive definitely I would say that
there is a tendency even in the West
words this you know backlash yeah yeah
okay yeah I'm very interested in the
fact that you have some women who are
claiming their religion to find sources
in religion to to empower themselves so
that's interesting that they wouldn't
you know give the religion away in the
hands of men but saying no we we have to
claim it and to say that it have been
interpreted for centuries for for even
you know more than centuries by men and
now if we reread the whole history we
can have a feminist a female
interpretation of it and be at the
center of its history Ellen yeah I think
there's really no lack of women's
artistic output and creativity it's
really I think an issue of the
gatekeepers and when museums open their
minds up to exploring different kinds of
artistic expression looking for new
artists you know it's a tremendously
important thing and it's interesting now
coming to Germany when I was named
director of this
the door to film museum in January there
was a story and artnet news this year
there's eight women not that have been
named directors of German museums
it's a record but the headline was still
a glass ceiling because all of the women
running museums are underpaid I think
getting people into these gatekeeper
positions in every community in every
artistic organization will change the
way that people are encouraged and
inspired and who gets access to telling
their stories because it's really about
who's driving the narrative who's in
charge of telling their story but who
are the gatekeepers of religion they are
men it's the Pope it's the shape priests
so even if you try whatever you can in
order to make reinterpretation and to
say this is wrong and you are not right
and I can do whatever I want they will
still insist on putting their own
stories out there and not in order not
to give you the power that you are
claiming so it's actually about power
it's about who are the gatekeepers not
just in film or in culture it's
everywhere who are the gatekeepers of
the of this of this world in politics
it's the same you know you can alike in
my country there are now six deputies
out of 128 deputies six deputies are
women but unless we have more women in
politics we won't be able to have the
laws that we are fighting for still in
Saudi Arabia and other places it is the
men who are giving you what is your hope
right sorry sorry go ahead
you know I I want to just add I think
it's not only about power of course it
is but it is also about strategy so if
you are in a position of powerlessness
and if you can only claim power in a
very limited way at least you must try
to do that which is what is happening
and I think also I want to suggest also
to you Ellen can we maybe rethink this
whole question of the glass ceiling
because it seems to me that the glass
ceiling is almost I mean it's always
ever
articulated in terms of money because
who's earning the larger amount of money
was getting to the top but in many
professions like yours like mine many
others women are the ones who are
controlling the content they are the
ones who are so in publishing in India
for example all the heads of all the
editorial heads are women and I'm pretty
sure this is the case in many places in
the world all the CEOs are men because
they earn the money but actually what's
more important cash or thought and ideas
and in that I think we've cracked that
glass ceiling well they add something
about the fact that I think that being
an activist acting for equality and for
justice is not asking for justice it's
just you know getting it taking it and
it's taking so it's challenging the
structure of thought I would give you
just it's a yes they just silence you to
silence you and like the right to drive
and to look good and to look good but
unfortunately many women are and I'm not
I mean again I don't want to be
pessimistic but when many women are
easily silenced because of different
factors I'm talking about you know being
intimidated into into staying silent or
these social pressure to just don't make
a big fuss about it don't make a scandal
out of it all of these things I mean I
hope you haven't heard them but I have
no I have it's true but many are not and
I'm simply saying turn your focus yes
focus on the ones who are speaking out
no I would like to poke those who are
not speaking up in order to make that
nice because I was just gonna circle
back to what you're saying and just the
gender equality notion that you know
there's a scale of economy in every
industry and artistic production in
publishing or the film business and what
I would advocate is that if you're doing
the same job you should just be paid the
same and of course that's become a big
issue
you can circling back to me too and
times up is it's not just access to
those jobs it's if you're doing the same
job are you actually being paid the same
and there's been some scandalous numbers
coming out about salient female and male
co-stars
and you know American film productions
and it's shaming people and it's I
really have to say that the the process
of bringing this to light and bringing
people out you know calling them out is
very very effective I don't think that
if it weren't for the shame of some of
these high-profile media figures being
accused in such a public way and all
their friends and neighbors and their
families know exactly what they did that
shame is quite powerful and it's also
happening sort of shady has been you
know notice an access to employment and
access to equal pay that gets us a seat
at the table and that means that we are
presented in a broader way in the
culture so you are sitting at the head
of the table at the German Film
Institute just tell us what what are
your next projects what how has the
discussion everything we're talking
about affected how you plan to conduct
these five years of your first contract
I'll call it will women and women's
representation in film be an issue for
you oh absolutely and in fact I've
inherited an institution that was
already very focused on that and my
previous direct the previous director
was a woman and there's strong women in
all of the you know department heads of
that institutions so we're screening
women's films on a regular basis there's
tremendous film festival activity where
women's voices are being front and
center and the content of our
exhibitions and the content of our
collections is trying to overcome the
historical gap I mean often people say
there aren't enough you know
high-profile talented women filmmakers
to elect into the Academy for example
they need to be given that opportunity
and you need to find young filmmakers
and you need to encourage mid-career
filmmakers because many many artists
make a movie and then they don't end up
getting another chance that 10 years can
go by before another project gets made
so it's finding filmmakers at every
stage of their career and giving them a
public forum inviting them to speak to
the audiences that's a very fundamental
approach to also sharing world cultures
our museum is involved in showing film
from
every corner of the globe and that's a
major major project for us is to make
sure we're not only focused you know on
one nationality or you know one more
mode of expression mm-hmm
okay Jumana you've made the move into
politics which I mentioned earlier and
you're talking now about this the
difference culture politics have your
have your goals changed and what way
have they changed and is is there more
acceptance for what you're bringing
forward in Lebanon well it's not that my
goals have changed you know I've been
fighting for women's rights and human
rights in general because it also to me
it I mean feminism includes everything
it's about being a human being it's
about fighting for equal rights and
opportunities for everyone I mean no
matter what your race or sexuality or
sexual orientation etc is and this is
very I mean all these matters all these
issues are very much linked in in my
part of the world and in Lebanon so
fighting for freedom of expression and
fighting for equal rights as much as
fighting for the right of it for
education for all kids not just the rich
kids get to go and get a good education
and this is also part of the problem
because you know the masses are not
having the opportunity to be aware to be
enlightened to have what they need to
have in order to work their minds all of
these pushed me to to go into politics
but to me it's like a continuity with
what I have been doing so far and I will
never stop being a writer okay that's
that's good to hear first they come over
to you of okay yeah what's next on your
agenda and and in the context is
incredibly complex so I have the
commentary in the pipe but I'm still
working on the on the following steps of
a book that I co-authored with her it's
a picture book that I co-authored with a
photographer which name is afro which is
a picture booth at each that displays
people from women from African descent
with natural off her hair because it's
something that we didn't have a chance
to speak about beauty standards but that
something that oppressed women or women
and especially women that
very far from the white beauty standards
yes exactly so we have interviewed 100
more than 100 140 people women from
African descent about how they feel
wearing natural hair and the place that
we have picked was Paris because it's my
birthplace and we have made an
exhibition based on the book which I
which was quite quite which was quite a
success in Paris so it's moving to some
other parts of France
in Marseille in the suburbs of Paris and
I hope that this will be more it will be
moving even in Africa so and suffocation
date the the book is available it's
named afro and it's coated with pointed
zambia photographer and we have people
from the cultural spaces hip hop artists
at the former Minister of Justice
singers and people you know teachers
accountants people who just enjoy it
just a way to show that beauty includes
everyone including people who doesn't
who don't look like you know what you
connect to beautiful women when you when
you google beautiful women all the women
like that you see our white women you
never see Asian women or black women so
I wanted to just change that narrative
about beauty absolutely stir things up
and get some more diversity or Vashi
what what are your are your you've been
working for 35 years as a feminist just
slogging away and achieving so much what
are your goals
now having well I mean the simplest way
to put it is my goal I think all our
goal is to change the world and make it
a more inclusive world where women are
respected where everyone actually yeah
has a right to a life of dignity and
respect it sounds like a big thing to
say but to me that's what feminism is
about but most specifically within my
publishing house in India our goal our
mandate our immediate priority is to
focus as much as possible on the voices
of marginalized women so to look at low
caste women to look at queer women to
look at Muslim women and women of
different minorities to look at trans
women
and to capture their stories so that we
can in some way nuance the story of
India and Indian women by including all
their diversity and not only focusing on
the voices of women like me who come
from privileged and who are educated and
that's really we can do that
in the few years that I as an older
woman have left to publish I think I'll
be happy I know we have different levels
of optimism on this panel but just a
quick answer from all of you just a
really short one are we on the verge of
anew with all the friction that we've
just been discussing are we on the verge
of a nude site-geist Ellen Harrington I
certainly hope so I couldn't take it if
we weren't moving in the right direction
in some way oh you mana
definitely yes tomb ism there it is okay
yes we are especially because because we
have new means to connect we have never
been able to connect in such a way as
today so that's something that makes me
positive and optimistic it's good and
lots of Hope obviously we wouldn't be
doing what we're doing if we didn't have
hope or Russia I don't word yeah are you
about your own optimism I don't know
what we are on the verge off but
whatever it is it's really important and
it's going to change reality in very
fundamental ways and we had better be
ready for it thank you very much to all
of our panelists we will be ready for it
Pattaya Ellen Harrington Jumana dogs
rock I had yellow thank you very much
for being with us at the global media
forum for this very interesting and
lively discussion and thank you to all
of our audience give yourselves a round
of applause women in culture obviously
working at the forefront for many many
centuries and they will continue to do
so a lot of optimism in the room here
and we are on the verge of something
possibly a new type Geist thanks for
joining us
[Applause]
[Music]